turning point 4 which is a 3/4 of the
movie so we're three quarters in the
major setback talk about that yeah the
hero of the story has been pursuing this
visible goal from the beginning of act 2
okay once they have this finish line
that they much must cross but your
audience and your readers rooting for
them to achieve by the end of the story
all the way through as they pursued this
the obstacles have been getting bigger
and bigger finally your hero at the 3/4
mark if it's a screen player somewhere
around that if it's a novel is going to
encounter an obstacle they can't
overcome it's going to be something that
defeats them and it must seem to your
readers or to your audience like all is
lost
like now oh my god there's no way
they're going to succeed at achieving
this goal and the hero gives up because
their plan is out the window and they
have no idea how they're going to
achieve the goal now so if you take a
movie like Titanic what happens is the
ship is sinking and finally it gets so
scary and the obstacles are so great
when Cal heard jerk of a boyfriend comes
along and say I found the lifeboat for
you she gets on the lifeboat even though
she knows it means leaving Jack and we
all realize if she leaves Jack the Leo
DiCaprio character on the ship and she
gets on the lifeboat all is going to be
lost
ok so that's the major setback there or
it's in a recent movie a really sort of
tight thriller called don't don't
breathe that came out a few weeks ago
before this video was made there it's a
very simple thing they're trying to rob
a blind guy of some money and the blind
guy knows they're in his house and have
locked them inside so it's just it's
kind of a haunted house movie but no
ghosts it's just a very intense
closed-in claustrophobic thriller and
that I believe if I remember it
correctly what happens at the major
setback is one of the main characters
gets killed by the blind guy and now
there's only one person left and she has
to somehow escape
so it seems like there's no way of
getting out of this situation okay when
that happens the hero is going to
retreat they're not only going to try
and go back to where they were living at
the set up but they're also on the inner
journey level going to retreat into
their identity they're going to go back
into that protective persona where they
were emotionally shut down at the
beginning of the story they're saying to
themselves I knew this was stupid I knew
I never should have gone for this I
shouldn't have opened up I shouldn't
have tried to find true love I shouldn't
have tried to take this emotional risk
you see what happens if you're writing a
love story or a romantic comedy the two
lovers must break up at this point you
have to split them apart and the hero
will go back and say I'm never gonna
fall in love again hitch is a good
example of that because the truth comes
out she finds out he's really the date
doctor he assumes she assumes the Evy
Mendez character assumes that Will
Smith's character has been lying to her
they break up and he gives up he says to
Albert I got nothing
it's stupid to fall in love you can get
past it it's I'm not going to jump out
of a plane without a parachute
and so the character will retreat back
into that safe emotional place but it's
not a fulfilling place that's the rule
they can't have what they want and they
can't live a fulfilled evolved existence
if they stay in that identity and once
we have experienced our essence like
these characters have as they move
closer to the goal going back fully into
our identity doesn't really cut it
anymore because we can't pretend like
that's who we truly are we've actually
had the experience in real life and in
story form of living a more fulfilled
existence so after that retreat the
hero's going to realize doesn't matter
what it costs I've got to keep going
after what I want I've got to be that
courageous and then they go into what I
call the final push and that Stage five
of the six stages where they put
everything on the line in order to
achieve that outer motivation they're
either
win or they're gonna die trying and the
climax is just the scene which must
resolve that question they either win or
they lose you can't be ambiguous about
it if they win it means they're fully in
their essence if they aren't fully in
their essence they must lose and then
the final stage is simply what I call
the aftermath it's the after picture the
before and after picture of the story
creates the before picture was a hero
fully in his identity the after picture
is a hero fully in his or her essence
reaping the rewards of having found the
courage to complete that arc
you